Salvy Michael capital will be telling us
about practicing in Mexico well thanks
for the introduction
thanks for inviting as well it's very
nice to be here so I will talk about our
recent work that gives an optimal space
lower bound for approximately max cut
this is joint work with Dmitry Gretchen
who is at the University of Geneva ok so
this talk is about graph algorithms that
use a small amount of space the reason
why we're interested is the fact that
modern graphs are large and they usually
do not fit into the memory of a single
compute node so we're interested in
designing small space algorithms for
graphs and in particular understanding
limitations of small space algorithms
for graphs so these limitations are
exactly what the stock is about ok so
this is about small space algorithm so
graph problems the standard way of
thinking about this algorithms is to
think about the streaming model of
computation also known as the graph
streaming or the semi streaming model of
computation so here our input is a graph
G has n vertices and M edges and the
edge set of the graph is revealed to the
algorithm one edge of the time these are
provided in a worst-case order now as
the algorithm is scanning the stream
this constraint and space usage it can
only use au tilde and space so n poly
log and space think of being able to
store say a small number smallish number
of spanning trees but not not much more
than that
now as the algorithm is scanning the
stream at the it's maintaining the small
space representation and at the end of
the day the algorithm must output the
answer so in this talk we're interested
in single pass algorithms so I take a
single pass over the edge stream ok so
this space requirement of n poly log n
is a very natural upper bound to ensure
um the reason is that for many
fundamental graph problems Omega and
space is needed for instance if an even
if I want to check if my graph is
connected even though my outputs output
size is 1 bit I still need a linear
amount of space and some settings so
even the object that I'm trying to
compute is Omega n size so it's natural
that Omega n space is needed that's why
I'm poly log n space upper bound for
semi streaming is quite reasonable on
the other hand many graphs are actually
sparse in real
so it would be very nice today to design
algorithms that operate in this truly
sub linear regime namely use space sub
linear in the number of vertices and the
number of vertices of the graph and over
the past few years we so there has been
a lot of work on designing such
algorithm so we know that for instance
we can approximate matching size in
random order streams using a very small
amount of space approximate the number
of components a number of connected
components in a graph using exactly a
very small number amount of space and we
want to understand for which other graph
problems one can design algorithms that
approximate the solution cost in truly
sub linear that is little o of n space
now in this talk I'm interested in the
max cut problem let me remind you we're
given a graph G so here's a graph
pictured on the slide and the task is to
find a cut that maximizes the number of
edges that cross it for this particular
graph G and the slide this cut here is
optimal it cuts all the edges but one
and the graph contains the triangles is
not bipartite okay well what do we know
about approximating max cut now
first let's let's see what do we know
about it in the RAM model of computation
for instance a random cut cuts half of
the edges in the graph this gives us a
trivial factor-2 approximation just
count the number of edges in the graph
I'll put that much by two we can do
better using Goodman's williamson this
gives about a 1.14 approximation it is
also possible to do better than to
better than this trivial trivial
approximation factor using spectral
techniques for instance the work of
Travis and Colleen Seshadri and sold on
ok so these are offline algorithms for
approximating max cut what exactly does
this tell us about streaming so how can
you implement them in streaming model
well first this trivial factor-2
approximation immediately carries over
to the streaming setting well indeed
using just the logarithmic amount of
space I can count the number of edges in
the graph and then output that much by 2
so that's a trivial factor on the other
hand if I want a good approximation to
max cut can actually get an arbitrarily
good approximation 1 plus epsilon
approximation in space roughly linear in
the number of nodes just sample about n
over epsilon squared
the uniform at random from the graph
find the max cut value there so note
that I'm interested in the value not in
the cut itself and I want to want my
algorithm to run and little off in space
now this is of course not efficient but
it gives a 1 plus minus epsilon
approximation in small smallish space so
the question that I'm interested in is
well here we have these two extremes
trivial factor to enlarge space and 1
plus Epsilon in above linear space do
non-trivial algorithms exist that
somehow fit in between these two
extremes yes yes yes we're definitely
fine with randomized algorithms but so
we won't understand if there exists
non-trivial algorithms for approximating
maxcut in the single fast streaming
model and the main result of this work
is that they essentially do not okay
good so this problem in fact has been
studied over the past few years there
have been quite a lot of works and
progressively mmm some less optimistic
questions have been asked about the
space complexity of this problem so for
instance question one was asking about
2014 perhaps they're just they're just
good approximation algorithms but use
let's say poly logarithmic space
similarly to approximating matching size
well it turns out the answer is no
because even a better than factor 2
requires squared and space was proved
proven by myself can ensue done and
cognitive growth gamma roughly at the
same time now this left over the
question of perhaps there is so to speak
an approximation scheme namely for any
approximation factor alpha between 1 & 2
maybe there is some beta such that I can
get a alpha approximation n to the beta
space maybe beta goes to 1 as alpha goes
to 1 this turned out to be not possible
this is the work of myself soo-dong
bellanger from soda 17 but there's still
left over the possibility of their
existing some magical constants alpha
star
perhaps the guns Williamson constant
such that you can approximately get an
alpha star for oxidation in some n to
the beta star space which is strongly
sublinear sort of less than less than n
and what we show in this work is that
this this is not possible what we show
is that any better than factor 2
requires linear space from the point of
view of new techniques essentially a lot
more is needed to get from question to
the question 3 then to get from question
1 to question ok good so let me now
formally state our result we show that
for any constant epsilon bigger than 0
any single paths would possibly render
my streaming algorithm that approximates
maxcut value to a factor of 2 minus
Epsilon requires linear space
specifically the amount of space needed
is Omega of M divided by 1 over epsilon
to the order 1 over epsilon squared so
there's some exponential dependence on 1
over epsilon squared I will talk about
this in more detail later so this
essentially settles the streaming
complexity of single pass algorithms for
approximating maxcut and well the main
innovation that lets us get the results
is a set of new techniques for for
improving communication complexity lower
bounds
via Fourier analysis ok there are no
good algorithms for mac scott and the in
the single pass setting at the same time
it does seem quite plausible that if for
example we allow ourselves a logarithmic
number of passes then space about square
root n are actually a little bit better
than that seems entirely entirely
plausible to be very nice to construct
such algorithms
okay yes because I mean like some of the
the results that go better than do they
do random walks yes that's exactly what
I have in mind so really what I want to
say is that suppose that we make this a
random order assumption so that at least
I can do what grrrrrr if Nick length
random walks that's why I wanted I think
it's it seems plausible although it's
definitely not clear how to get it that
you can beat factor two in some sub
linear sub linear space that'll be very
interesting okay good so this is the
main results now let me tell you how we
get there if we were establish the
theorem by analyzing defining and
analyzing a hard distribution of input
instances that looks like this our
distribution is based on random graphs
they're almost like order for any rough
but not quite so there's there will be a
yes case and a no case and the yet yes
to minus one of our get approximation is
over here to minus 1 over log n
approximation I see good so this lower
bound would would rule out yeah no I'm
not aware of any loved any upper bound
of the stuff of this type for single
pass algorithms no
yeah so I'll proof as I will show is
actually fairly tight for the
communication complexity problem but we
yeah but for general graphs I'm not
aware of socialism so here's the Hardin
for distribution there is a yes case and
in the yes case our algorithm will be
presented with a random bipartite graph
with expected degree about one over
epsilon squared so that's 1 goes to 0
the expected degree gets large in the no
case it will be a random non micro tight
graph with expected degree 1 over
epsilon squared technically it's a multi
graph but the edge multiplicities are no
more than two with extremely high
probability and the number of double
edges is order 1 over 1 over epsilon
squared so there's almost none so what
we will show is well in the yes case max
cut value is all the edges in the graph
because it's a bipartite graph in the no
case because the graph is dense enough
or we'll need this 1 over the average
degree to be 1 over epsilon squared to
be large enough the max cut value is 1
plus order epsilon times 1/2 of the
number of edges so the graph is almost
half one one-half were far from being by
protecting 1/2 minus epsilon so so
better than 2 minus epsilon factor
approximation to max cut must assume
distinguish between these two cases so
it's enough to concentrate on proving
that no no algorithm with less than
linear space you can distinguish between
the two ok how do we what do these
graphs look like well as I mentioned
it's important that in the no case the
graph is dense enough that's because we
want the max cut gap to be large enough
on the other hand how should this graph
be presented in the stream in both cases
the stream is naturally partitioned into
capital T which is roughly 1 over
epsilon squared phases and in every
phase what we see is is a uniform layer
is a random matching welcome the yes
case and in the no case locally the
graph is very sparse and Max and and
sparse in bipartite it's just around
here's a pictorial representation the
input stream will be partitioned into
about 1 over epsilon squared phases and
in every phase we get a random matching
of size alpha and alpha is some small
constant okay so here's what the stream
looks like as I said
locally mm and if we look at any fixed
chunk this is every fixed in any fixed
phase of the stream then both in the yes
and of the mill cases we will see a
uniformly random matching except the
matchings and the yes case are
correlated in fact there is a uniformly
random by partition of the graph that is
sampled at first and then every mashing
that we get in fact mashes vertices in
one side of the by partition two
vertices on the other side of the market
issue there's no case there is no
correlation and these you can think of
this is just resampling the by partition
in every face okay something yes case
this is a bipartite graph and in the no
case this graph is far from Lyford well
we want to prove that no small space
algorithm separates you can can
distinguish between the two it is
natural to prove this prove this bound
by considering a tea party communication
problem
so there are tea players corresponding
to the phases in the stream and every
player after receiving the corresponding
graph bossed the message MMI on the
board and the borders is visible to all
the players no the last player at the
end of the stream must announce the
answer are we in the yes case are we in
the no keys now it is not so easy to
reason about compressing graphs so
instead we reason about compressing to
define a different communication problem
and reason about compressing bit string
bit strings so let me tell you about
this problem so it's the implicit
implicit hidden partition problem
introduced in our work in soda 17 the
problem is as follows so this is a
problem which is a relative of the
boolean hidden matching problem so there
will be tea players player 1 through
player tea and every player receives two
pieces of input what will the first
piece of input is a gruff say player 1
gets G 1 here's the graph with labels W
1 on the edges of G 1 say here the
labels shown invent
where the graphs are public as soon as
the player receives the graph the graph
was posted on a board the bits the
labels are private so the player looks
at the labels and rides down some
message on the board that depends on the
lathe
this goes on for two rounds and then the
teeth player must distinguish between
the two cases in the yes case there
exists a bi partition of the graph that
is a zero on labeling of the vertices
such that the labels that we observe on
the edges are consistent with that by
partitioning so friends in particular
the label of on an edge EUV is just X u
+ XV the labels on the two vertices mod
2 another way of saying this is the in
the yes case the edges that have ones
written on them are exactly the edges
that go from one side of the by
partition to the other and the ones with
0 are the complement so we can write
this as WT the labels are just M 2 m T
times X to our M T is the edge incidence
matrix of the graph okay and in the no
case no such partition exists yes
messages are on the board so there's the
last player they can see the message of
the first player and second yes that's
correct the messages are on the board
yeah the graphs are on the board and the
messages are on the board so you don't
lose anything by considering that model
compares to one really make a trip for
the code where they cannot see correct
one could potentially lose but one could
potentially lose but the number of
phases is only one over epsilon squared
and the lower bound is actually n over 1
over epsilon to the 1 over epsilon
squared so this is not really important
ok good so this is the problem and so it
is important here that this partition X
is never given to any player and that's
why it's the implicit hidden partition
so we use the following distributional
version of this problem
so here the bipartition X is chosen
uniformly at random and then the game
with probability 1/2 is in the yes case
with probability 1/2 is in the no case
the distribution of the graphs that the
players are given at are as follows
so the graphs g1 through GT are simply
random matches so here's the pictorial
representation of the graphs so say the
first player gets a uniformly random
matching it's the red players it gets
the red matching the second player and
of course together with bits on the
edges the second player gets again a
uniformly random matching say they're
blue matching well it's a uniformly
random one so it's better to draw it
like this
then the third player again gets a
matching so the black player got this
black matching and let's say the fourth
player gets one other matching if you
put these matchings together you get a
graph that somewhat resembles an
erdos-renyi graph above the giant
component threshold that's that's why
she was the average degree to be 1 over
epsilon squared the graphs the graph is
indeed written on the board so as soon
as the chief player gets the Gesta input
the teeth graph so the chief matching is
written on the board so it is important
that player T does not know a graph T
plus 1 so basically they know all the
graphs in retrospect so basically as
soon as the teeth player gets a graph as
it gets their chunk of the input what do
they get they get a graph GT which is
nothing but a random matching so this
matching is posted on the board in its
entirety and then there's also the
private input wishes the bits on the
edges these bits are not the course
posted then the player compresses the
bits and posts the message so in
particular one the player does that the
player can adapt to all the graphs g1
through GT no the player one starts
first
sent good so let's see so there it's a
tea player game we start with player 1
player 1 gets a graph G 1 the graph is
immediately posted on the board the
labels the labels are compressed and
posted on the board then player 2 gets G
2 it's posted on the board so in
particular the teeth player can adapt to
all the graphs and all the messages on
the board yes I have not so that's
exactly what I'm about to do a short
good so what does this have to do with
maxcut what does this problem have to do
with Max Cup let me tell you how to
create the stream I promise to you that
will in the yes case will create a
random bipartite graph and in the no
case will create a random non bipartite
graph how do we do that well every teeth
player when they receive the
corresponding graph GT looks at the
labels and then starts the graph GT
prime but contains all the edges that
have one written on okay so in the yes
case all the labels that we saw were
consistent with some by partition so the
edges that have once written on them are
exactly the ones that cross the cut just
like this edge here 0 to 1 and so the
union of these graphs GT prime is
bipartite in the no case the labels were
uniformly random so what the players did
was basically just take a union of
random matching matchings and then
subsample the edges independently at
rate 1/2 so this is the distribution ok
I'm good so what we show is that the
corresponding graphs G prime that are
created on the yes case it's bipartite
in the no case is actually 1/2 minus
epsilon far from by pretend this is
almost by journal bounce what needs to
be a little bit careful because they
have matching so there's correlations
good so at this point we have the
reduction so we need to prove we need to
understand the complexity of the
implicit hidden partition problem so on
what we show is that any T player
protocol that gets a constant advantage
over and I'm guessing for the implicit
hidden partition problem must use at
least n divided by T to the order T
communication and remember T was 1 over
epsilon squared so this recovers
original okay good
it was interesting to note that here we
have an exponential dependence on T and
it might might look weak in reality as I
will show in a few minutes there do
exist protocols for this problem with
the complexity and over a constant to
the T so this is potentially a little
bit weak and it's we might know how to
remove this weakness but it's better we
prefer not to do this because the
analysis is easier okay good so in the
remaining time I would like to talk
about the explain the main ideas behind
the proof of the theorem now before I
tell you how we analyze the implicit
hidden partition problem for general
protocols I would like to give some
intuition I would like to start with
start by designing some simple protocols
for this implicit hidden partition
problem you can see how they perform
okay
secures the problem we have a number of
players and for simplicity let's say we
have four players so there's the red
player the blue player the black player
and the orange player if each player
gets a uniformly random matching here
they are overlaid the union of the
matching this is on the slide the
players also get bits on the edges of
the matching these bits are not shown
here so what is what is a natural
protocol for this so what is the goal of
the players the players want to know if
these bits are consistent with some by
partition or if these bits are uniformly
round so a plane but here's a very
simple protocol for this problem every
player when they get the corresponding
matching somehow decides on which edges
the player wants to convey information
about and it will be a zero one protocol
in the sense that we choose some some
subset of edges and we convey the bits
on those edges and we convey nothing
about the bits on the rest of the edges
and I claimed that we'll call these
edges revealed edges and I claim that if
at the end of the day our players put
together the revealed edges if the set
of revealed edges contains a cycle then
the players get advantage over and I'm
guessing let me convince you that this
is the case so here's an example let's
say the red player got this red matching
his inputs and now here are the bits
we are in the yes case who are only
thinking about the yes case in this case
so here on the vertices of the graph I
have this bits corresponding to the
random by partition and the edges of the
red matching matching our labeled
according for the second and what are
this zero but only the one agent
upcoming or zero is the one edges are
coming yes so basically if I want to
yeah if your if your question is how do
you create the stream out of this
communication problem you just filter in
the communication problem you get a
random matching you just sort of filter
the matching you keep only those edges
that have once so there's in the
communication problem every player gets
a matching with a bit you keep only
those edges that have ones written on
them and you feed them into your stream
you okay
so here's the first red player and the
player looks at the edges and somehow
decides that the player wants to keep
these two edges they're shown in bold
and the corresponding bits are posted on
the board the other bits are just
forgotten it's very nice so now the blue
player comes and gets the random
matching here it is decides to keep
these two bold edges and the other bits
are forgotten and now the black player
comes in and decides to keep something
so maybe this one one black edge with
the corresponding bit and finally the
orange player comes in looks looks at us
and decides maybe to keep these bold
orange edges all right so now if we look
at this picture the the bold edges are
the ones that we transmitted information
over and we noticed that there is a four
cycle there's a cycle which contains
this black edge this blue orange and and
and red so now if we are in the yes case
then if I sum up the bits on these edges
I get a zero because we in the yes case
the edge has a one written on it if it
crosses this hidden by partition and
then walking around the cycle so if I
come back to the origin I crossed an
even number of
on the other hand if we were indeed no
case then to over any set of edges the
bits add up to possible 0 or 1 with
equal probability they're uniformly
random so if the players create a cycle
then they can solve the problem good all
right so that's a simple class of
protocols now let's let's try to figure
out I said somehow they choose some
subset of edges to to convey the
information over let's look at concrete
examples which edges should we should we
use so here's a very simple strategy the
simple strategy is this the players
remember that the the union of the
matchings its end it looks essentially
like a brand-new graph suppose that the
players just look at a sub graph of this
graph so they they they look at the
vertices with labels between 1 and
something and decide to keep only those
edges that have both endpoints in this
special set so here here are these
vertices shaded in cyan and a very
natural prodigal is just keeping the
edges that have both endpoints in this
set the players are basically hoping
that a fixed induced subgraph of this or
any rough will have a cycle well every
player also should not convey too many
edges and one can do some computations
to figure out under which conditions on
the communication complexity of the
players the players will be able to
detect a cycle and a pretty simple
calculation that is basically computing
the expected degree in this induced
subgraph and noting that you will get a
cycle as long as the graph is above the
giant component threshold suggests that
with this type of protocol I will be
able to detect a cycle only when the
communication per player is bigger than
n over T squared so N or poly T T was
the number of players but on the other
hand what reaches of our result seems
the law one seems weaker and in the
light of this now in fact the truth is
that this protocol is very weak this is
not a very good product all to have in
mind when one thinks about lower bounds
for this problem so let me give you a
better one so this is just not a very
good way of figuring out which edges to
keep
the problem with this protocol is that
it's non-adaptive let's consider a very
natural adaptive ski we call it the
adaptive component grow in protocol and
this protocol will in fact be a very
good very good good model for the actual
lower bound proof one can think of the
law one proof is basically showing that
this is essentially the essentially the
the best you can do okay so again we
have these t players and our players
will maintain forests ft somewhat ft B
the forests formed by the edges that are
revealed by the players by time T so
recall that as soon as they get a cycle
the game was over the players won the
game so that's why we're thinking about
forests and now the teeth player will do
the following the teeth player will look
at the forest ft minus 1 and the teeth
player has a budget of s bit this player
will look at the forest and reveal all
the reveal the edges that actually have
at least one endpoint incident on on
vertices that are in the forest in
non-trivial components and of course the
player will stop doing this when they
run out of budget here's an example so
note that this is very adaptive what can
you do an example so say the first
player the red player got this red
matching I'm not showing the bits
anymore because this is more about the
edges at this point so we look at this
red matching and at this point there is
no ft minus 1 F 0 was empty so the
player just selects 2 edges to keep very
good so now the blue player comes in and
gets this blue matching okay suppose the
player has a budget of 2 edges so the
player will keep those edges that that
have such that at least one endpoint is
incident on the forest constructed so
far so the player will keep let's save
this edge and this edge because they
intersect with the red ones so they're
growing the components faster now the
black player comes in gets a matching
and actually keep something but at this
point they already have a triangle here
is a track
okay good look so note that this is an
adaptive process where every time the
players have at time T the players are
looking at a forest ft minus one and
then a random matching comes in if at
least one of the edges of the matching
also has both endpoints inside the
inside one of the connected components
in the forest the game is over there is
a cycle and the players win so I want to
understand suppose that at time T the
sizes of non-trivial connected
components in my forest are denoted by
CI what is the probability that the next
matching creates a cycle well a simple
calculation shows that this is the sum
of squares of component sizes and this
makes sense because for two components
for every component CI the probability
that an edge falls into it is about CI
size of CI squared divided by by by by n
so the sum of squares really governs
governs the process so the interesting
question to ask is for this particular
protocol how does this how does this sum
of squares of component sizes evolve and
again a certain amount of contemplation
reveals that these component sizes get
to grow exponentially because in every
round you pretty much get a perfect
matching and you can double the size of
a component not really double multiplied
by some constant factor and yet another
calculation shows that this means that
if you start with a budget which is only
and divided by something exponential in
the number of players after T steps you
will be able to find a cycle if you are
depth
okay very good it turns out that one can
also show that this protocol can not
solve the problem with more than n
divided by something exponential in T
communication and the way to do it is to
consider a potential function which is
nothing but the sum of squares of
component sizes one can show that not
only can one grow this potential
function exponentially it actually
cannot be grown more than exponentially
in one run and in T Rob's good okay very
nice so now equipped with these
observations let's see how we can port
them to an actual lower bound for
general problems so let me remind you
what the problem is again our problem is
there is a uniformly random partition
and then we have T players each player
gets a random matching with labels on
the edges and we want to know if these
labels are uniformly random or they are
mm or they are consistent with some by
partitioning in this distribution okay
so you don't want to say yes and no you
won't right that's an easier problem I
see I see I mean I don't think it would
be tremendously easy I wouldn't really
know how to do it very quickly this
because this protocol makes a serious
assumption it assumes that every player
either can either conveys the entire bit
about the edge or nothing so maybe there
is a better way of solving your problem
by doing factional things okay so let's
consider our distribution with four
players and this is what we want to
understand suppose that players 1 2 & 3
have spoken and now the the last player
player 4 is getting this random matching
with a bit what do you want to show want
to show that even conditioned on the
messages from players 1 2 & 3 the
distribution of the labels on the fourth
players random matching is close to
uniform so well this random by partition
used to be uniform before the player
spoke was uniform in the boolean Q now
conditioned on the message from player 1
and now player 1 gets to use arbitrary
protocols so conditioned on the message
of player 1 this X is the by partition
is uniformly random in some subset of
the cube conditioned on the message from
player 2 is uniform the random in some
blue subset and in the corresponding
orange subset from player 3 conditioned
on all of them X is uniformly random and
the in the in the intersection of these
of these three cells
so I call this sets a 1 a 2 and a 3 and
these sets have do not have small
density and the boolean cube most of the
time because the density is at least 2
to the minus s where s of the
communication okay so let F 1 F 2 F 3 be
the indicator functions of a1 a2 a3
respectively so here in order to bound
the distance between the distribution of
m4 x x and the uniform distribution we
use fourier techniques there were
pioneered in the work of gradients you
can pick your own Edison rods on the
boolean hidden matching problem and have
been developed since then the idea here
is that if X is uniformly random on some
subset of the bouillon cube then in
order to get a bound of this form on the
distance to uniformity one needs to
prove strong upper bounds on the sum of
squares of fourier coefficients of this
of the indicator of the set that X is
uniformly random in and these bounds
have to be parametrized by the weights
of the by the Hamming weight of these
fourier coefficients so this is our goal
we have a set which is the intersection
of a1 a2 a3 it's indicator is the
product of F 1 F 2 F 3 and we want to
understand the Fourier transform of this
okay good so let me relate this problem
to our component growing protocol which
is a good model for the proof so let's
just understand what is the Fourier
transform of the component growing
protocol so here is here's an example
maybe my players created two components
so far this blue orange and red and this
red and red let's think about the
corresponding function H that's the set
that X is uniformly random in and let's
try to understand this Fourier transform
well first it turns out to be useful to
not think about the Fourier transform H
hat but certain normalized Fourier
transform H tilde so let me talk about
just I'll replace all the hats with H
notice this is just a convenient rescale
okay so for the component growing
protocol the Fourier transform of the
corresponding function turns out to have
the following simple form or at least
the square of this function has a very
simple form the Fourier transform of a
coefficient of e note that this
coefficient is just a subset of them
is this in absolute value it's one if V
has an even intersection with the
components in the forest constructed by
by the player so far and is zero
otherwise this is just the Fourier
transform for linear subspace okay
that's very nice in particular let's
let's let's look at the amount of free
air mass on the second level of the
Fourier spectrum that is when the
vertices when the coefficients that were
summing over have credit and have
Hamming weight exactly two basically
let's understand how much our protocol
knows about pairs of vertices ooh really
H tilde of V is the amount of knowledge
that our protocol has about whether or
not the vertices in V are on the same
side of the by partition okay one can
convince oneself that the sum of squares
of Fourier coefficients over
coefficients of level two for the
component growing protocol is nothing
but the summation over all components of
the size of the corresponding component
choose 2 which is exactly the potential
function that I defined for the
component growing protocol that is we
sum the squares of Foraker of component
sizes over all non-trivial professions
in other words the potential function
that governed the the behavior of the
component growing protocol is actually
the sum of squares of Fourier
coefficients over over the second level
and we need to bound this such sums okay
good and so this motivates the following
proof plan we note that our goal because
we're using the boolean machinery is to
understand the amount of mass and
various levels of Fourier spectrum and
we just noted that for the component
drawing protocol the corresponding
amount of mass on the second level is
exactly the potential function that we
defined and we convinced ourselves
before that this potential function can
at most grow exponentially with the
number of players so this is what we
would like to do we'd like to prove for
general protocols that the sum of
squared for your coefficients over all
elements of the second
the fury of the spectrum is it most the
communication times something that grows
exponentially with with the number of
number of players okay now of course
we're working with general protocols so
the second level of the Fourier spectrum
is not going to be enough you need
higher order equivalents of this but
high order equivalents of this have a
very national form so let's see if we
can actually make this proof plan work
so far it looks like we can view general
particles simply as a relaxation of this
component okay okay good so yes f1
definitely does depend it does depend on
on f2 sorry f2 depends on f1 it's not
Phoenix yeah there are these
dependencies that's true the place where
they come up is in basically bounding
basically in a few slides a couple of
slides down the line basically once we
know these definitions as stated yes f2
depends on f1 f3 depends on f2 F for
depends on everything before that in
particular this means that when we bound
the Fourier spectrum we can't for
instance have much independence between
them the third player might for instance
easily adapt if the third player knows
that the second player conveyed put a
lot of for airmass on some elements of
the spectrum the third player might
decide to put more for airmass there as
well that does come up come up with it
but I will not really talk much about it
in this overview good so what is all
gold now on all gold is this so we have
this plan of basically emulating the
component drawing protocol
right now we are interested in
understanding the Fourier transform of
this function H what is this function H
T players have spoken every player's
message constrains X to be uniformly
random on some subset whose indicator as
the corresponding set F T so HT is the
product of the corresponding f T's we
want to understand the Fourier transform
of H hat T and we want to use the
structure of this function the fact that
it's a product of functions of the
matchings so we want to use something
inductive basically we start by proving
the corresponding bounds for just the
functions f TS that that the players
messages correspond to that turns out to
be pretty easy the reason is that these
functions are supported on matchings and
that's where you get an improvement from
the square root and bound and the
boolean hidden matching problem to a
linear bound here so that part is rather
straightforward now from here what we
want is to lift these bounds on the f TS
to a bound on HD for that we want to use
the convolution theorem as the Fourier
transform of a product of two functions
is the convolution of the corresponding
Fourier transforms now this idea of
using the convolution theorem was
recently used then I'll work with comma
Sudan and Belanger and recently with the
Jon Keller Eric price but here the
situation is harder because in both
those works the convolutions are
basically a product so they're a little
bit easier than here whereas in our
setting the convolution is as general as
it gets okay so the main technical
contribution is exactly the analysis of
this convolution for an arbitrarily
large number of players and the
challenge is the fact that the union of
the matchings actually has a giant
component i still have maybe two minutes
to therapy sure good it turns out
however that
while all prior works rely on l2 bounds
in the Fourier spectrum which comes out
naturally from hyper contractivity it
turns out that l2 bounds are not
sufficient to carry the inductive
hypothesis through and what we note is
that l1 bounds is our sufficient
substantially more robust I don't have
time to get into the details but one can
construct examples that show that
essentially to carry out the induction
what we need to prove is that basically
the Fourier spectrum was in some sense
close to sparse and our way of arguing
this is to upper bound the l1 norm of
the Fourier coefficients and various
levels of the spectrum which turns out
to be pretty small for a given LT l2
norm so for the individual FTS we first
upper bound the Fourier transform of the
squared norm from hyper-connectivity and
then use cauchy-schwarz this is exactly
what where it is important that the
graphs given by the players are very
sparse they're basically matchings
that's where the improvement comes from
and after that we use the we use the
convolution in the convolution theorem
the high or the high orders or the high
level idea here turns out to be the
following that because of the sparsity
of the graphs given by the giving to the
individual players we get stronger
bounds on the individual FTS and in
particular if you look at the second
level of the Fourier spectrum we get
exactly the behavior that we have for
the component growing protocol after
that using the convolution theorem we're
able to show that even though the
Fourier transform of this HT already
does not have this nice structure it's
not supported on a matching it still
maintains this property that l1 norm is
pretty small
before the vector of the same of a given
l2 mr despite the fact that this HT
could be supported in huge sense good so
the other high level high orbit is that
one can essentially think of our proof
as a l1 relaxation of the zero order
component growing protocol basically one
should compare a component growing
particle with space s to a general
protocol with space squared of s times
and slightly larger space
so that's a that's a summary of the
approach we get an optimal lower bunk
for approximating maxcut the main idea
is to upper bound the l1 more of the
Fourier spectrum as opposed to Lorne
which has been used in all prior works
and it would be very nice to see other
applications of l1 norm bounds on the
Fourier transform for graph problems
because this is exactly that
what makes this analysis work no no
that'll be very interesting especially
given that I would I would not be too
surprised if there was an efficient
algorithm for would say logarithmic
number of passes that is I don't think a
little linear bound I don't think holds
for these instances it's actually just
not true
so in order to allow small break let's
let's think Michael and take the rest
the next part soon